the comedy clubs of new york and i well
it would be strange for me to say that i
was and then not build up to that
wouldn't it just be like are you gonna
wrap for us then yes i don't know if you
know how show business works
i it would be like for what i was like i
have three testicles
obviously i would end the show
i am a rapper i do freestyle rap that's
wrap that's made up it's not written
it's not prepared it's not rehearsed
it's improvised in the moment it's super
fun and it's based on what you guys want
to hear a wrap about so it's entirely
directed by you so all you guys have to
do and pay attention to the little rules
first okay um think of a word or a topic
or a phrase but um try not to be boring
don't be like food or animals don't say
dog or pizza it's super dull so i'll be
eating like three seconds taking time
when i'll stick with tea and then
we will come
it's a wrap-around catheter where does
it wrap around
wraps around the penis and then into the
urethra you're explaining as if you've
gone through this
foley is the art of making sound so i
don't understand
yeah yeah probably artists would be able
to make sound effects for things but i
presumably mean something different
it's the guy who thought of it cool i
love that the guy he's like i think we
should put a thing inside a penis yeah
we'll name that after you oh [ __ ]
i think that the guy who invented it i
think foley was the name of the guy who
bullied him i think that
so foley catheter thank you i feel like
we could have gone to the same point we
just said catheter but i appreciate the
extra
learning experience that i've gone
through
so we need four more suggestions and
let's make it quicker than that so
let's come over here what you guys want
to wrap about
let's try and get our minds out of the
gutter
okay fine uterus people over there are
like no if we're rapping about catheters
we're wrapping about uterus as well um
what's the plural
mayor de blasio okay cool great mayor de
blasio uterus
area 51 um what are you what what what's
your opinion on area 51 it exists well
yeah it's on it's on google maps isn't
it but
would you would you take a job there no
no wow
i like my job what's your job
why wouldn't you tell me what's wrong
with that unless your answer is comedy
reviewer i
and i don't mind i've been i've been
doing this a long time
a management consultant okay cool a
management consultant's first day area
51 that's their suggestion med of lazio
uterus foley catheter this side of the
room you'd be neglected what would you
like a rap about
hurricane ida hurricane ida was that
that was the one that we we got the kind
of dregs off and it flooded but it it
did did bad things downtown but it was
like a category four when it hit was it
it was fun it's five now
it's still there
i know this was going fine but it looked
like the weirdest wave ever you just
was like off to school on the back of
the bus okay
well let's um let's have some fun with
this oh they they put a little connector
on there for me right um this is a
freestyle that is a wrap made up
with someone over there saying this
guy's sick that's very kind you've not
even seen it yet
um unless you're like oh no he's
mentally deranged he thinks he can
freestyle um this is a free start to
wrap metal from the spot based italian
suggestions the suggestions are
hurricane island foley catheter
[Music]
kangaroo can you rap about that mate i'm
like no chill it doesn't fit the bill
but i still give the thrill maybe get a
little catheter attach it to my dick i
say to the doctor can you put it in
cookie says you'll feel a little brick i
need some anaesthetic a problem with my
bladder so you know i better yeah i'd be
walking in there and he told me let me
explain how it works this a foley i'm
like i don't care about the name my
bladder's inflamed i just need it there
because i'm feeling the pain the spatula
[Music]
consultant saying i like my job chris i
wouldn't change but if you went to the
desert and looked at all the strange
ufos and the things inside what little
insight you could bring provide walking
in like don't worry yeah my choice made
maybe work for bcg or deloitte or even
what's all the cheering you like check
out the management consultant here and
he stores them away and uses them later
what would they have an intergalactic
potato or something like a little green
man you're like you need to downsize
that's the plan fire this alien fire
this swat team get out there they start
running to their team the aliens like oh
i'm new to this i want to do a little
[Music]
resist you'll feel a little cold i'm a
gynecologist from pluto i'm looking in
though oh look at the walls all the
shedding it goes every 28 days i can see
her after birth period that would be
called lokia
[Music]
hey everyone see me maybe when i die and
i depart from these mortal coils they
will name an airport after me but
probably not already got laguardia don't
know what he does is he good do you
cheer when he says things and he's like
yeah i'm in charge mayor of new york and
i'm having enlarged what does he do is
he good does anyone know you've got a
nice cut ban sat here in the show like
i'm shaking my head why cause i'm
confused what was the last thing that we
choose from views that we need to do
oh yes coming through people like we're
in distress our new york we got the tail
end it happened in the final of the us
open people get their cars they left
them on the bridge they were like queens
expressway i can't believe we did try
and drive down but wide at the mouth you
should pay more attention to what
happened down south like in lake charles
and in baton rouge they had a much worse
time than you dude but still admittedly
it's not that strange because unlike us
they probably deny climate change
[Applause]